[Music]
Hello everyone. My name is Jax and uh
I'm a founding engineer at Kskll Apps.
We build opensource human robots from
hardware to software to um machine
learning models and we build it
especially for developers. Yeah. So,
humanoids have been have been getting a
lot of hype recently. You sell the Tesla
Optimus, you have Uni robots, you have
uh 1X and etc. Um they're quite
proprietary and they're quite expensive.
And the humanoids are getting so much
hype is because of very big problems
like physical labor shortage, consumer
household and also like offro off
off-world exploration and etc. Yeah. So
for us at Kscale Labs, our goal is to
really solve general purpose uh robotics
for everyone and open sourcing the
entire stack to the entire world. So
everyone will be benefiting from this
really really useful technology instead
of a few different uh companies.
Yeah. And uh our team is about 15 people
in Palo Alto. Um you could visit us
anytime. We're launching some robots in
the next coming month. And uh yeah, I'll
be demoing some robots in the slides.
Cool. So, we're currently working on two
robots uh the Kbot and Zbot. The Kbot is
a 411 uh humanoid robot that we made in
last five months. Uh it has a full
aluminum body, runs a RL controller for
local motion, and it has a it's pretty
sensor complete. So, it can do all the
really cool tasks that um the previous
presenter was showing. And this will
also be one of the cheapest humanoid
robots on the market and it's ready for
pre-order right now. Delivered by
October.
Yeah. So if you come visit, this is a
demo we do. Uh you can kick the robot.
Um the controller is quite robust and
the robot is can take a lot of damage.
Um on the robot itself, you also have
basically you can do VR tell operation
with building hands. Um I'll describe
the modularity a bit more, but yeah.
So the robot's able to run a bunch of
different local manipulation policies
running our own RL training framework.
So when we started building the Kbot, we
thought about like how do we make human
humanoids scale in the future and what
makes it what makes it possible for
people to adopt humanoid robots. So we
basically designed this human robot to
be the simplest possible uh factor as
possible and it's going to be the most
affordable developer and research grade
human robot at $9,000. Uh the next
cheapest option is probably at 40k which
is the uni robot. Um this is roughly the
cost of most robot arms today. Like if
you buy UR5 that's I think 15k or etc.
So the entire robot is going to be open
source. What that means is we're going
to have open bomb. Every single piece of
the hardware, CAD design, electronics,
PCB, software, uh machine learning
models will be fully open sourced. So
you can replicate this um if you want
to. And it's also going to be very very
modular which means that um you can
basically change out end factors. We
have different mechanical designs that
you can easily make interface with our
uh end factors and you can just take out
uh the hand to for a parallel gripper
instead of a five uh five fingers hand
or you can use whatever endector you
want to use like the wmy grippers or
etc. And that means is we can also
easily upgrade and also fix the robot.
So our goal with selling this to
developers that when we have new
hardware updates, you can easily just
rescrew the robot in with brand new legs
or brand new arms and also um brand new
head. So you know as compute improves
like you get new Nvidia chips, you can
easily just add a new head onto the
robot. Um yeah, we're also building we
have built entire Python Rust SDK for
people to use. Um if you come visit us,
you can start programming this robot
basically immediately. It's like p
pipping style package and you can start
working on it and it's capable of
running the latest state-of-the-art ML
um algorithms. So in terms of local
motion you can use like Nvidia is sim uh
to train PO policy. We use MJX um which
I'll explain a bit later but you can use
all kinds of different frameworks. You
can also run like different VLMs like
language models on the robot maybe not
locally directly but you can run through
cloud or you can run uh VAS and etc as
well. Um so if this robot by default
it's going to be five do arms but you
can easily interchange to a seven do
arm. Um so that will suit most of the
research need research labs need and
we'll make continuous like model and
software improvements with OTAA uh
rollouts. So every every week basically
we'll make new changes to the software
as we go.
Yeah. Uh here are some more specs. I
can't release the full spec yet because
we're launching soon. Um but yeah, you
see it uses MIT Cheetah actuators uh
pretty standard components with like um
MUS uh just different audio modules,
displays, cameras um and up to 250 tops
compute currently.
Yeah. And we we really started this
project in about October last year. So
we've been moving pretty fast. We had
brought this to uh mass manufacturing
and we have a new basically design that
we completed that I can't show you now
but you'll be able to see in two weeks.
Yeah. So we started off this uh the Kbot
is like the Kscale Stompy project like a
full-sized humanoid robot that's 3D
printable. Then we moved to like a
prototype and we work with different
manufacturing partners to actually make
the new one uh that you see.
Yeah, it's launching soon if you're
interested. um in a K-pop. You can go to
kscow.dev.
Yeah. I'll give you a second. No, I'm
not done. Whoa. That's only one robot.
Not even one third finished. Joking.
Yeah. And so what if what if you can't
spend $9,000 on a cool human robot? Um
what if your like wife or husband
doesn't allow you to do it? Well,
introducing the Zbot, which is a 1 ft
five um 1.5 feet uh humanoid robot that
we also made at Kscale Labs. So, this
started from a hackathon project we did.
Um it became really popular on Twitter
and also WeChat. And so, we're bringing
this robot to mass mass manufacturing as
well. It runs the same local motion and
software stack. Like that means you can
basically program stuff in uh for the
small robot but you can also put it on
the big robot. So you know if you make
like a voice chatting app you can just
put it on the idle robots and it runs
also local motion policy as well. It
works out with all the simulators. Um
yeah we really got inspired by the
Google Deep Minds uh robot soccer robot
soccer paper where you know it runs
around play soccer. That's really how we
were envisioning it. So yeah um
We have a pretty good the launch went
really well for the 3D printing one. So,
our Discord has about 5,000 people. I
think a few hundred people have actually
made a 3D printed one on the the orange
one on the bottom.
Yeah. So, we also started this project
in November and we are already bringing
it to mass manufacturing which will also
be launching very soon. Um, some people
Yeah. We also run like monthly
hackathons so you can just come try out
the robot. Yeah.
Yeah, same same website. Okay. Okay. Um,
that's the hardware stuff. We talked
about the hardware components. We just
open sourced. Oh, yeah. Also, Zeba will
be fully open sourced as well. Um, and
so we also open source our entire ML and
software stack. So really like our core
end goal is basically to make this um
make the Kbot autonomous. Well, so you
know it's a pretty standard uh dual
policy. You have the high level
controller which is a VLA. Then you have
the RL whole body local motion policy.
Yeah.
So what we really want right now is to
basically finish we're currently working
on both basically the RO part and also
the VA part. And we also made our own uh
firmware software architecture to power
these robots in Rust.
Yeah. Our end goal is basically to make
the robot so easy to use. Um any
developer could write apps for robots.
So you know Python application that you
can reshare with people you make the
robot do some very specific use cases
that can be reused by other people. It's
almost like a app store and to do that
basically um we offer a lot of really
cool developer tools we've been working
on in last six months. So we open
sourced the library for basically GPU
accelerated robot learning. Well it's
mostly like local motion manipulation
training. Uh we use MJX for this and
yeah the the video if you saw us kicking
the robot it runs the controller our
controller uh our model that we train in
this uh training framework.
Yeah we also are working on to basically
being able to integrate and fine-tune
all the different VA and generalist
policies that you see from PI zero also
Nvidia group that we're also presenting
today. So this robot will be able to
run, you know, we're trying to make the
infrastructure very easy to run any cool
models that you see. That would be
useful.
Yeah, we also made this uh operating
system which is like a software
framework plus like a Python interface
that you can use to program the robot
using Python or Rust. So, you know, you
can just instead of I don't know if you
guys use Ross one, Ross 2, they're
pretty hard to set up, but using our
system, you can just install Python
package like PIB install Kos and you can
start programming robot. You just
connect to IP. It's very, very easy to
use. And we also have a digital twin in
simulation. We call it a KS sim. It has
the same gRPC interface you can use for
uh controlling robot in simulation. And
all you have to do between programming
something in simulation and real is by
changing the IP address. So you can
prototype really really rapidly without
having to worry about breaking the robot
which is very cool. So yeah this is also
fully open sourced. Uh you can try today
you can actually program the robot um
just by using KSN.
Oh, I don't know what happened to the
images, but yeah. And then what the what
basically what the machine learning and
the operating system layers enables for
us to run different policies, VA models
and on our robot hardware and for people
to develop really cool applications
with.
So yeah, I'm just going to go through
like a very very quick uh RO training
and deployment examples of how um
researchers and developers could use our
robot to train a local manipulation
policy for the robot to you know grab
different things or walk around or even
dense.
So yeah our training setup is very easy.
You just get clone the repository and
then all you have to do is run python-m
and in this train.py Pi is you
effectively have all the training code
you need uh abstracted. It's about 500
lines for walking.
Yeah. And then basically you can run
this on like you know using runp your
local GPU. It's MJX so it's like you
know it's accelerated um accelerated
compute and training a walking policy
roughly takes one hour to uh two hours
and yeah so you're just going to run
through like millions of different um
not examples uh yeah iterations of the
robot performing task you want and you
can tune the reward functions and etc
and you can see the loss and reward
functions in um our observability
basically tensorboard um yeah and
afterward words when the robots finish
training you can easily evaluate it in
cosm. Uh so all you have to do is like K
uh K inverse like you run the policy.
Yeah. And in simulation and you see the
robot if it's walking if well if you can
see if it's doing the thing you want it
to be doing for example like walking
standing uh picking up objects and if
that's really good in simulation then
you can just easily change the IP
address and then you have SIM to
deployment.
Yeah. And uh it's very cool like you can
basically get a robot to work in like
onetenth of the time of like what you
would take to set up most uh training
libraries right now.
And also like we're a team of 15 people.
So we do everything from hardware to
software to ML. So how we're able to do
this is actually by working with our
open source community. Currently we have
about like 5,000 relative act active
discore members in a few servers. We
have a lot of public open bounties that
people are tackling and of our because
of our software MIT licensed. Yeah. A
lot of people are coming to help us and
we also run hackathons almost on by
monthly basis that a lot of people come
to participate.
Yeah. So we're also hiring electrical
firmware and ML engineers. So if you're
interested, feel free to uh ask me and
then also go on the kcot.dev
joint website. Um yeah, we're trying to
hire a lot more cracked people to join
us.
Yeah, so we're launching a robots and
software stack in about two three weeks.
Um if you're interested, follow on the
website. I'll be h happy to answer any
questions.
[Applause]
Yeah. Yeah. Sounds good. Uh, go ahead.
Yes.
Where's the power? Where's the power?
The battery.
Yeah. Yeah, it's battery packed. Yeah,
it just has a battery. I don't know if I
can show you in the picture. Yeah, it's
behind this basically. You can just slot
in like it clicks in. Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah. The weight of the battery versus
longevity. What do you mean? Yeah.
Longevity. Oh, like how long is Yeah. Uh
walking so far our test is about two
hours, but you can pass through. So you
can power through the wall plug. So it's
Yeah. You can just keep letting it
charge and also run at the same time.
Yeah.
Yes.
Uh well, black jacket. Yeah.
What are the use cases that you guys are
imagining to start off with? Is this
going to be more for like commercial
like you know factory kind of use cases
or do you envision this more in the home
like helping out? Yeah. So basically our
bet so a lot of companies like
especially in the US are betting on like
B2B. So like figure for example are
selling to factories since Tesla itself
is the customer. For us, our really bet
is be becoming the first US consumer
robotics company like robot humanoid
robotics company. Yeah. So really
selling it to anyone that's interested
in developing robotics. So a lot of our
current customers, we accidentally
launched our robots like people
accidentally start started buying our
robots through our Shopify page. Um that
was a complete mistake. But a lot of
people that bought were just people
genuinely interested in using for
household task like programming it for
different research and also there are a
lot of companies also interested in
working with us um to make B2B
businesses like for example the food um
food demo that we just saw. Yeah.
Sorry if I can ask a follow like what
household like chores do you think it
would be well suited for like unloading
the dishwasher for example? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean right now right now we don't have
any I don't think anyone really has a
fully working VA model yet. So right now
it's pretty limited to TA operating
system uh sorry TA operation. So yeah um
but soon we we hope to be able to have
like this navigation VA stack for you to
do like you know folding clothes or like
doing dishwashing as the model
capabilities improve you. Yes. White
white shirt.
Oh I mean green shirt. Yeah you can go
first. Can I ask? Yeah, of course. Okay.
Yeah. Uh, so the um you kind of alluded
to complexity of Ross 2 in terms of the
setup. Uh I'm wondering if there were
other like benefits and trade-offs that
you considered for foregoing something
like Ross and Ross 2 in that ecosystem.
Oh yeah. Like why not use Ross
basically? Yeah. Well, there are a lot
of reasons. Um our robot is mostly
programmed. So Ross is really good
because like the nodes and stuff, right?
So like the async like the communication
but for our robot we really don't have
that many sensors and we really want to
do this like model based like policy
based robot so we don't have many
complicated sensor that we need to like
async communicate at all times. Um the
other part is like we're I'm pretty
opinionated. I used to Ross one and Ross
2, Foxy and uh Noetic. Um I've just had
a pretty bad experience using it having
to set up Yubontu, you know, like I just
want a robot I can just buy uh buy open
the box a stands for walks and then I
can just start programming it using my
computer. Yeah.
Yeah.
What what kind of AI acceler
kind of AI accelerator is on each of the
robots? Yeah. So um basically for the
Kbot it's going to be JSON NO and AGX.
Yeah. So
yeah there are different compute options
you'll be able to choose when we launch.
Yes. Yeah. Go ahead.
Uh so you can just put either VR
headset. So there are few different
methods. So the preferred option for a
lot of people's VR headset. We have this
like we also train like a pseudo IK. So
basically it's like a going to position
using like a RL model instead of just
like calculating IK but it works pretty
well with our VR setup. So you can move
the hand gestures, you can click button
to open and close gripper and just yeah
move your arm and stuff.
Yes. Yeah, you'll be able to it runs the
exact same software stack. Yeah. Last
question. How do you compare with Tesla?
The Tesla humanoids uh in terms of like
mechanical poweress like you know the
Tesla is way more powerful. It has like
linear actuators and etc. But in terms
of like actual use cases, I don't think
it's really that different. Yeah. I mean
Tesla is actually built for like a
factory type of uh use cases. But in
terms of like you want to for people to
actually buy and use this robot, it's
not very different. What's the price
difference? Uh I think the last time I
heard Tesla Optimus is about 60K at
least. Um we can ask some Tesla
engineers,
but uh our robot is $9,000 before mass
production.
[Music]